google has trained artificial
intelligence to manipulate nuclear
fusion deep mind the ai division of all
seeing eye search engine google has
opened up a pathway for the arrival of
unlimited energy nuclear fusion is how
the sun powers itself using gravity to
extract continuous energy and to harness
it as pickled scientists for decades on
earth to do the same a nuclear reactor
has to be heated to hundreds of millions
of degrees to transform matter into
plasma keep it stable then extract the
energy with magnets the collapse between
edf and swiss plasma center deep mind ai
was taught 20 years of continuously
updated research to control the plasma
by taking 19 measurements 10 000 times a
second and adjusting the magnetic field
accordingly it's claimed this
breakthrough of harnessing energy could
be as impactful in human history as
electricity was all this talk of power
does make you think with the amount of
digital power and data google already
possesses chuck into the mix unlimited
nuclear power controlled by ai what
comes next